[Music]
foreign
what happens when one
seemingly non-negotiable need is pitted
against another so so the example I want
to ask you about specifically is
attachment versus authenticity right so
if I think about the the
reaction I had to my significant other
this morning which was similar to your
taxi experience yeah on one hand I
wanted to be very direct in how I was
feeling and then I hesitated in
expressing that which would have come
with a tone of anger almost certainly
because I wanted
her acceptance and support didn't want
to hurt her and so I felt this
inner conflict
of needs that I couldn't reconcile and
maybe that's not the best example but I
would love for you to sort of help me
and the listeners explore this a bit
because I can't be can't imagine I'm the
only one who experiences this type of
thing
I don't know
I wasn't there and I don't know what
happened but my guess is that
you and I did this exercise once before
without you very uh I thought rather
bravely put on YouTube
where we went through a certain
experience of yours so you haven't been
upset the lesson from that exercise and
I imagine and very often or take my
reaction at the airport
and I imagine perhaps your reaction this
morning and I can't say this for sure
because I wasn't there but very often we
don't react to What happens we react to
an interpretation of what happens right
so that your partner did or didn't say
or do something
and then you had a certain
interpretation of that
and then you react to that
interpretation so I imagine that may
have happened
but more generally speaking so then
you're in this dilemma if I fully
Express what I feel I'm gonna maybe
heard her and heard the relationship or
heard them and hurt their relationship
but if I don't
then I'm not being authentic
so what do I do I mean nothing has to
dilemma that you're posing here
it goes back to very early in childhood
because we have these two needs that
I've identified one of them is for
attachment attachment being our need for
connection and closeness with another
person for the sake of being taken care
of
or for the sake of taking care of the
other so when I talked about these brain
circuits of Dr panksab the care system
is designed for you and I to take care
of the vulnerable
our young our very old ones or sick ones
there's a system in our brain with its
own brain chemicals and its own
circuits that are designed to help us
care for one another
That's essential for no mammal would
survive without that
they also
have a system for what he calls grief
and panic and that's what we experience
when we don't get that care you know so
we're wired to attach for the sake of
survival and no creature is more
dependent more vulnerable
more immature than a human infant
compared to any other animal
so our dependence is absolute so our
need to attach is absolute
but we have another need
as creatures and then as human beings
which is to be authentic now I don't
need any kind of new age
who who concept by this I mean no
knowing what we feel and being able to
how to act on what we feel so
you know as as you know we evolved uh
out there in nature
how long does any creature
in nature survive if they don't know
what the gut feelings are telling them
not very long not very long that
authenticity which comes from the word
Auto for self knowing ourselves
and manifesting ourselves is an also
essential need that's fine
but what happens
if
a child experiences emotions
that the environment says Ah
we won't accept you with that
that can happen through abuse
but it can also happen through
well-meaning parents who read the
parenting advice of
a lot of experts including some that I
think you've had on your program who who
will tell you that when a kid is angry
there should be mate to sit by
themselves great let's name some names
here
who are we talking about Jordan Peterson
says that in his book 12s rules for life
ah an angry child should be made to sit
by themselves until he says they come
back to normal in other words anger in a
child is not normal but he's not the
only one and the message to the child is
you're not acceptable when you have that
emotion
no
now the child is a dilemma
I can be authentic
but then they're gonna exclude me
if that's gonna threaten my attachment
relationship
or I can suppress my authenticity
and then I'll have the attachment
now what do you think has sacrificed 100
of the time
authenticity the authenticity gets
sacrificed and then spend the rest of
our lives trying to figure out who the
heck we are
and that suppression of authenticity has
severe mental and physical health
implications
from autoimmune disease to malignancy to
depression takes for example something
like called depression
what does it mean to depress something
literally what does it mean push down to
push it down depression is not this
inherited brain disease
is the result of having to push oneself
down push someone's emotions as a child